it's not only to bring the data in by
the way when people think the ingestion
piece and the connectors this is
big things yeah it's it's it's yes it's
a challenge
but but then once you solve the problem
you know the the way that you integrate
everything to one smooth data model
that provide the value for the business
this is the biggest the biggest mission
that i see it
welcome to 20-minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with leumitech sponsored
by hippo insurance
opposed labs touring hillel at stanford
leap and in media partnership with ctec
this one is going to be all about data
operations welcome ita
benjamin the ceo and co-founder of
rivery
a dataops platform that streamlines data
integration transformation and
orchestration
a seasoned business executive ben hema
was co-founder and ceo of vision bi
a leading data consulting firm inquired
by curious group at kiris benjamin was
group vice president
for north america itamar holds a bsc in
computer and information systems
security from the ben gurion university
of the negev
itam al benjamin welcome to 20 minute
leaders all the way from austin texas
how are you
great thank you thank you michael for
having me
oh good thank you for joining me i know
you're generally new york but you're in
austin with your new offices
for for your amazing startup which we're
going to talk about soon your
expertise in data ops and business
intelligence runs way deeper than just
your current
endeavor and we're going to talk about
that as well but
i have to start from your army days a
two to two year back to back i guess
record holder for the disaster
run and i never did the disaster and i
want to re-enlist just to do it
what is it what is the disaster run yeah
yeah most of the entrepreneurs in israel
you know they are coming from
the 8200 division uh i'm
i'm not i'm parachuters i was an officer
in uh
i led like what we call the
department or in in the israeli army in
the parish
the parachuters so when i was in the
in the in the what they called bodhichat
which is
the um the officer school um
so there is a disaster run or what they
call disaster bodyguard everyone knows
that
uh after two days in a row that you are
doing uh
food navigating of 90 kilometers then
you have
what they call disaster run it's an exam
uh
and i broke the record and i uh i broke
it for
two seconds uh i didn't know the the
before uh but my friend which is really
great athletes he told me run run really
quick because you are
going to break the record so i just did
my best and eventually i either end up
with a
16 minute 32 seconds which
broke in two seconds uh i hold the
record for two
two years uh it was a just a side story
of my life
that that's amazing you know the the
extent of my physical training in bad
and the commander's academy was doing
maybe 19 push-ups and barely finishing
them so
so i think we had a little bit of a
different experience but that's okay
uh we're here talking together on this
show and we're
we're not going to talk about you know
commanding and well maybe a little bit
commending because it has a lot of
leadership lessons but
i want to talk about your experience
with business intelligence and data ops
so itama throughout your experience walk
me through the bigger
milestones on your journey and how each
one
has helped shape your understanding of
business intelligence and the power of
data in organizations
yeah i think i'm uh maybe one of the
oldest people
uh data people in at least in israel uh
you know i uh i built data warehouses uh
since 2000 uh when i started my career
wow um and uh i spoke about data
warehouses when people
didn't know what is data warehouse and
then uh
so it was a great experience after the
after school
i um i studied in uh busy
and uh engineering um and i
you know i just built uh data warehouses
an analytics platform for living like
for more than two
twenty years like two decades um
we saw a lot of transitions over the
time i think the
um the biggest one was uh when i learned
you know where the river is my third
company i built another two companies
one in new york and one in israel
both of them really successful but they
were they it was like
assets and product internal products
that we built
but we basically we devel delivered the
projects and
you know we worked with 500 customers so
we
knew the problem we saw it uh but then
you know when i think that was the thing
that pushed me to
to go all the way with reverie is that
the transition that you see now in the
market
when companies dealing with the data
operation missions
which is more much more complex than
than we had in the past because of their
fragmented of data
um and then other other challenges like
moving to cloud or digital
transformation business that wants to
move
more involved in the in the data space
so uh i think that those are the things
that
uh push me um like i call it from
service to sas
um and provide the same value or maybe
even better value
as a sas organization and not not as a
service provider
now so take me up you know 30 000 feet
in the air and and
share with me your understanding of the
power
of of data or business intelligence in
general in organizations and
and where we are today in 2021 so what
i'm hearing from you is you've actually
been
building these tools for organizations
since the very early 2000s
and you know i've been in this space for
maybe seven or eight years and
i i know that i was also you know in the
beginning of it
uh i've seen organizations even in 2013
and 2014 so
so where are we today and what's
happening
i think that we are now in the when uh
when organizations understand the value
of the data uh
the organization really um willing to
invest
and invest a lot of money uh in order to
be a data driven
organization um even you know taking uh
like um consumer packaging goods
companies like companies
that you know not the natural
uh organization that used to invest in
data now
everyone understands that the power of
it um i think that
uh the biggest changes the biggest uh
difference you know from the old days
that i used to build data warehouses uh
in the early of the 2000s
is that you have more and and
very different sources um every company
you know when i built the first data
warehouses it was uh one or two erp
you had the sap you know for the maximum
you had another one crm and
uh you know i built i i managed the
biggest project in israel
at that time i think in 2005 in silcom
and they had 30 system um now
even with the re we wanted to build our
internal
internal data warehouse analytics we we
have
more than 25 sources so uh so this is
the biggest
the biggest challenge it's not only to
bring the data in by the way
when people think the ingestion piece
and the connectors this is
big things yeah it's it's it's yes it's
a challenge
but but then once you solve the problem
you know the
the way that you integrate everything to
one smooth
data model that provide the value for
the business this is the biggest
the biggest mission that i see it um
yeah right so with this growing
fragmentation what i'm hearing you say
is
you know we're we've built a lot of
tools which
a lot of different you know models a lot
of ways in which to store data we've
we've
and now we've entered this new phase in
in data intelligence world where
we have this you know we have this
crazy amount of data we have crazy
amount of connectors and and we're still
left with
with these big open questions how do we
actually integrate this data together
and how do we actually put it to good
use for a company
and and i'm assuming that you know with
rivery or also understanding there's
also
a bunch of low-hanging fruit where you
know just the world has become
much very complicated but if you're able
to simplify it then you're going to
bring some amazing results talk to me a
little bit about this integration with
rivery
yeah i think that um
the if you if you follow the revolutions
in the in the data space you see that
um business users wanted to get more
access to the data and then you saw
product like tableau or like click you
know with the self-service approach then
later on
with the with size and sloka we call it
data visualization but it's actually
um self-service user experience um
then you know i think that five years
later um
with snowflake bigquery um
with you know those those data
warehouses or data lakes in the cloud
they came to solve the problem of okay
we now we have the business user to
to consume the data um but now you know
we are moving to cloud we want to have
the data is growing we don't need to add
another server
let's use it as a sas and and those that
was the time that
uh snowflake and bigquery and and some
other players
came into the market um and i believe
that
the next revolution or what we think now
is the data ops
why because um the challenge
of you know to have as an organization
that they were doing uh migration to
cloud or
digital transformation so you have the
tool the storage tool you have the
data visualization tool but you don't
have the the orchestrator you don't have
the operator that
to manage the ingestion and
transformation and
you know catalog cataloging of the data
sets the entities and
and all with the same value that we had
from traditional tools like informatica
but
in the much quicker much faster and the
ease of use that the the current
business wants to see
right so obviously with a company like
referee i'm assuming that
you know a subset of the organizations
truly understand and are huge champions
of what you do
if you do your job well enough then the
rest of the organization doesn't even
necessarily need to know
that river is behind the is the brain
that is integrating all this amazing
data that is leading to the amazing
intelligence
and so in these in the next few minutes
i'd love you to share with me
how you're imagining this world with
reverie integrated and
and how is the world looking different
as we approach the next few years
where these integrations are simpler
where the companies have the business
intelligence
available to them as they needed asking
the right questions
what in other words what impact does
rivery end up having as a butterfly
effect
on our society
i think uh you know uh zero
uh almost zero definition
uh that you want to put in your let's
say
data model and in order to build the the
the most efficient data model that can
be consumed by the business users this
is
this is the goal this is the the the
vision um
i'm you know on the on the way there you
have uh some
milestones so you started with uh you
know the connectors which we are trying
to be like
uh really zero um development on this
one
but then you have we grew to the data
model which is the
the biggest thing i think in our product
uh specifically for
the the the growing uh the hyper growth
companies
that you have several business units in
the organization and you want to make
sure that
each one of them they will use uh what
we call virtual data model that's
relevant for their needs
um and it's old and i think this is the
brain behind river is uh
is that the fact that we can build for
you the
or you built with with our platform your
data platform
by having the the based on the metadata
that you that you have
and and this is the biggest thing that
our engine
built the data warehouse whether if it's
snowflake data breaks uh
google aws you can build
in in you know very few minutes
uh entire data warehouse that based on
metadata
that you uh get from the sources right
and i think that one of the things that
you know as you're explaining this the
and and i'm imagining the simplicity and
you know i have the added advantage that
i've been thinking about this space for
a long time and i think for an
outsider you know a lot of people are
talking about impact today
in the world and they're asking what
impact does does your company do and
a lot of people miss out i think on the
idea you know my conviction is that
companies like yourself
are the ones that are going to make the
biggest social impact on the world and
it's very not counter-intuitive
what you're doing is you're enabling
organizations to
leverage data better to have better
insight to be more efficient
and obviously hopefully the right
organizations will be using this service
but
but you but your impact is not
measurable but we know it's going to be
amazing as more and more user reverie
right and i think that's a really
important
thing to know in the industry is people
are talking about impact
data ops and what you're doing is is
just as big as impact if not more
than any other company that claims we're
here to do impact right
yeah absolutely i think it's the best
compliment that i could get
for what we are doing and uh so thank
you for that michael
uh i uh yeah i really i strong believe
on this one
uh for for living i uh again
with my previous two companies that i
built i met so many businesses
and i um let's say build really strong
hundreds of
employees in north america and in israel
that build those kind of projects i'm
not saying that
river we will replace this one but it's
make it more efficient
make it more value for the business i
think for our customer and
their customer let's say the partners
customers and uh yeah so this is the
the impact that we're trying to do and
people think always you know
yeah but the data visualization tool is
the most important thing here
it's it's important definitely important
but if you will ask the
data scientist yeah it's nice that you
have the tableau but i need to have the
data in place in order so to build my my
uh
my algorithm so uh it depends on the the
consumer
right and i definitely can understand
the pain point on it on a daily basis
and so i'm
a very strong consumer on that end it
why do you like data so much you've been
in the space for dozens of years
why
why i think i love it i think i uh
i think i love the data um you know when
i
um i have a passion to uh
to be i'm a builder and you know i have
a passion to build the companies
um when i build the first vision bi with
my two co-founders in israel seagal and
ilan we it was
really great uh experience we worked
with the best companies in israel
all the best names in israel and we
worked with them for their
to build their first data warehouse or
first analytics platform
um best partner of snowflake in email
not only in israel so
i think that we we did a great success
but after four or five years i
i decided i told my my co-founders look
we need to do something abroad we need
to
to to do something else uh outside of
israel
and then you know what is what is the
best city in the world for me
you know i like the new york so i wanted
to be in new york every quarter so i
decided to build
the new york office or the new york
company um
so it was uh yeah and it's also started
really small in the beginning
kind of bootstrap not kind of bootsweb
real butcher
and we we grew in very few years from uh
you know very few people
to over 140 people with six or seven
offices in north america
um yeah it was really amazing journey um
and i you know when i came to my dad my
father is the one that
he doesn't know anything about what i'm
doing it's not from the tech
nothing uh but but he's the best person
to consult with when i told him that i
want to go back to riveri
uh to build riveria the um you know to
go to
another time and the third time to be a
startup he told me
you're so different than me but uh you
know you will succeed i know that
uh so yeah so i like it i guess that i
love it i love the building
thank you so much for this episode i
loved it i have a few questions left
about you not about data and not about
reverie
and i want you to take me back to middle
school or high school childhood days
what fascinated you as a kid what is
your favorite subject
in school or a passion that you had
i i always liked math and
math and sport i think that was the best
thing even now uh
the the best thing that i like i'm you
know um
i supposed to be a soccer player
professional soccer player
i never succeed i wasn't so good so i
decided to focus on math
so now i'm checking the the parameters
the
the hcv the arr and all the metrics
you need to know something in math in
order to succeed and who would be a
source of inspiration for you
throughout your career or journey uh
personal professional
so i i yeah i think that i learned from
many many people uh i um i mentioned
my dad uh and that is nothing nothing in
the tech but uh
you know my dad we lost his wife my mom
when he was uh
when she was 37 years old you know with
four kids
young really young um and the way that
he led
us to the family uh his community
basically the way that he led
us and and gave us the the confidence
that we can
we can grow from this strategy strategy
uh i think that
you know for me will always be uh you
know a person to consult with
i in the product i learned things from
elon musk you know about
if you are competing in the in the
markets that exist in market
you you you cannot be slight better than
your competitor you need to be
much better and this is what we that's
what what we want to do in riverweed
and yeah and what are three words that
you would use to describe yourself
oh and i think honesty i'm
really counting myself as an honest
person um
sometimes things too much of the table
but i think honestly it's one of my my
you know
passion uh i'm passionate for what i'm
doing i don't care about
um i care about money but the
more important about what i'm doing and
uh and the passion that i have to what
what i'm doing um and uh yeah i think uh
as i mentioned i'm a builder i like to
build i'm not the guy to
you know i have other partners always in
the business to to make sure that we
have the maintenance and everything
uh but uh i'm i always like to look
ahead amazing
and have a great rest of the day best of
luck thank you
it looks amazing i look forward to
checking out the product and and playing
around with it as
a data engineer and that's that's what i
do a lot so
so thank you for sharing with me inside
the domain it was wonderful
and uh you know stay safe and stay
healthy thank you for everything
thank you so much thank you micah really
enjoyed
you